so today we're talking about well
rocking a bit but mostly I want to talk
about cogeneration which is obviously
low if you know about a rocket it's
obviously what sort of makes rocket
rocket
I think cogeneration is a somewhat
underappreciated and sometimes way over
appreciated feature of rust but I think
if you use it well you get really nice
api's that actually help you write
better code or help you write better
software and I like to think rocket is
an instantiation of that I if we can use
cogeneration well then we can get good
applications good software so the way I
want to structure this talk is sort of
in three three stages first I want to
introduce you to to rock it if you don't
know about rocket it's a what I think is
a simple fast and tight site type safe
web framework for rust you know say a
bit about what I mean by simple and type
safe fast is self descriptive and it's
powered by rust cogeneration without
Russ cogeneration we wouldn't have
rocket and the idea is that rocket lets
you write secure and robust web
applications in a way that nothing else
really lets you do the closest that
other web primers get is are those in
languages like Haskell using something
like type Haskell or some point yeah
whatever templates yes template Haskell
thank you that's the right word template
Haskell great then don't want to talk
about cogeneration so after you get to
know a little about a little bit about
how rocket looks how rocket code looks
and what rocket does I want to talk
about cogeneration in rocket and in rust
so when rocket was launched there was
this pervasive comment about how rocket
was so magical
how rocket was like rails and it's magic
in like to avoid it like the plague
because it's too much magic and I want
to demystify that I think cogeneration
isn't magic I think monkey-patching and
Ruby mix-ins are magic but not
cogeneration and in doing so I want to
show you very briefly what the
cogeneration api's look like and when I
say that I mean the procedure
macro api's which are very similar to
what you can do now with derive if
you've used that and then I want to talk
about a bit a bit about the future so
what's coming in future versions of
rocket and how rocket will continue to
use code generation to give you a nice
interface and in really strong promises
so that's that's sort of the the the
path we're taking for the talk today
quick introduction on rocket spend about
10 15 minutes on that if you already
know rocket feel free to doze off for 15
minutes
then we'll talk about cogeneration and
rocket let you know how rocky needs
cogeneration what rocket actually does
what cody generates and how that works
and we'll talk a bit about the future of
rocket ok so let's start with a finished
introduction to rocket so again rocket
is a web framework for rust that ideally
makes it simple
ie like it's very easy to read very easy
to write to write fast web applications
what you would expect from a program
written and we're in rust without
sacrificing flexibility so you can do
what you want to do not what the
framework wants you to do or type safety
and I've underlined all of these things
but I really want to underline type
safety it's it's interesting that if you
write a program in rust it doesn't mean
your program actually takes advantage of
type safety ie you can dynamically cast
and rust you're not aware and that's
like a really nice escape hatch if
you're coming from the web because the
web is the string you're trying to take
this string and make sense of it in rust
but if that's what we do if we really do
just dynamically cast things then we're
not really using the power of rust that
the power of a static strict strong type
system that rusts gives us and rocket
aims to exploit that type system so
that's what I mean by type safe there so
how did we get to rocket so this is the
timeline and every time I do a talk and
rocket this timeline gets you know wider
which is nice so rocket launched about
seven eight months ago eight months ago
or so and shortly thereafter there was a
version 2.2 about a brought a bunch of
nice stuff to rocket and about five
months after that there was a release of
version 0.3
just last month and now we're at the end
there it's gained awesome traction there
are at least thousands of users and a
couple dozen companies using it which is
pretty awesome something that's not on
this timeline that totally surprised me
was was this blip here was how quickly
someone told me hey I just launched
something in production and my company
is now using rocket it was like two
weeks after rocket launched I got an IRC
message saying I rewrote this thing in
rocket thanks so much I can throw away
node I was like all right cool that's
great thanks for using version 0.1 I
appreciate that
so that was quick you know now when I
get those kinds of messages I'm more
excited than scared or nervous I think
but it was surprising how quickly that
happened just as a bit of fanfare here
when rocket launch did you know I got
really nice coverage hacker news loves
thrust sometimes but they generally
liked rocket so much so that rocket was
the top trending project when we
launched which I thought was awesome so
I got over a thousand stars in the first
day I'm github so that was fantastic ok
so this is the timeline
now obviously I'm missing a big
component of this timeline which is what
happened before you know the launch and
well obviously I worked on it that's
what happened before the launch so I've
been working I've been working on rocket
for quite some time about you know eight
nine months before rocket actually
launched and mostly a full-time effort
kind of have to step back from rust for
a few months in the middle
mostly full-time effort and I just want
to give a very tiny blur above about why
rocket exists it wasn't just to create a
new web framework because there are so
many of those in so many different
languages you know it's like stop no
more web frameworks you know I believe
that so why did I make rocket well yeah
I've worked on the web for a very long
time writing web applications for a very
long time and I've been writing rust for
less time obviously has existed that
long but almost five years now
like four years so way before one point
out and at some point I wanted to marry
the two ideas I was like yeah let me
write a web application and rust let's
see how this works and I tried doing it
and it was not fun when I programmer I
like to have fun otherwise I just
thought programming and it was not fun
and it was not taking advantage of the
type system and for those two reasons
rocket came into existence it was really
an idea of how do we actually make this
super easy
even though Russ type system is not
always easiest thing to use and at the
same time how do we take advantage of
that type system even though we're gonna
make it easy to do this okay so rocket
web framing for us makes it simple to
write fast web applications without
sacrificing flexibility or type safety
great so let's take a look at what a
rocket application looks like this is
hello world it's four lines this is
really all you write well caveat you
need a main function and yeah so this is
what you write and first of all I just I
just think it's so cool that you can
write this and this is rust you know
like this is like a sea successor and
you're writing this I just think it's
awesome so what what is this what are
you looking at well first thing up top
here is an attribute if you guys are
familiar with rust so it's an attribute
and in russian rocket we call it the
route attribute it's a description of
matching conditions
it tells rocket these things have to be
true for a web request to be routed to
this route for rocket to give a web
request to this route these conditions
have to be true so in this case you need
a HTTP request with the get method to
the route path the thing at the bottom
is the route handler it's just the
function it's not a special function
it's just the function and it will be
called if the route matches and rot and
rocket will call it and it'll produce a
response which is an arbitrary type
choose the type as long as they diplomat
cesarean type class you can return it
and that's it that's really what makes
up rocket applications are these routes
and if you were to actually run this
thing and you were to go to the root
path
well you'd see hello as you would expect
that's that's really all it takes to
write a HelloWorld application in in
rocket now like I said you do need a
main function so this is not the 100%
complete application and the main
function looks like this so this is the
main function and there are a couple of
things that are happening here
the first thing you see is this rocket
ignite so obviously I need to turn on
the rocket if you're going to launch
this thing so you ignite the rocket and
then you need to put some stuff on the
rocket in this case when you put routes
on the rocket because those belong in
space apparently so you mount some stuff
on the rocket and what mounting means is
you just name space the route so for
instance here we're not really
increasing anything so we're just saying
mounted to the root path but if I were
to change that to /hello
for instance then every route in sort of
the list of routes would have to be
prepended with slash hello in order for
rocket to route things to it and then
finally you launch the rocket and that
starts up the server and it also prints
a bunch of emojis which is a contentious
point
it was like ii github issue after a
rocket launched emojis stop please they
don't want that but that looks like this
you get three emojis you know not so bad
when you launch it you get this thing
rocket tells you rocket tries to be very
very helpful while you develop the
application it tells you everything it
knows about the environment you know
where you're where it's actually serving
this thing the configuration of your
application it tells you what routes it
knows about and finally it tells you
where your application is actually being
served and you know emojis no more
emojis after this just three emojis but
still a lot of backlash so be careful if
you choose to put emojis in your
applications you also can't get rid of
them which is great you can try they'll
come back alright
mounting and launching great so that's
that's what our full application looks
like pretty simple this this is really
all you're right obviously need to like
extra and crate rocket and things of
that nature but this is really the
entire application alright so this is
fine right this is like cool we can
write a hello world but we can't really
do anything particularly interesting yet
from what I've shown you we can change
the path so we can change get / - for
instance get slash world and now we'd
have to go to localhost localhost 8080
get to you know slash Sergio and then
we'd have to go to localhost 8080
but immediately we can do more and of
course you can do more and so I want to
talk to you about dynamic pads so don't
worry pads as the name implies allows
you to have path segments that are
dynamic ie the user tells you what the
value for that path segment is and so
here is our we worked hello world
example and you can see that we have
parameters in brackets in the route
attribute so we have name in brackets
and that makes something dynamic so
whatever the user types in to the path
at that segment will be the value that
the name parameter gets and so again
these are in brackets that's how you
tell rocket hey this is dynamic I don't
mean the literal slash name
I mean the dynamic name and you can do
more than these you can do more than
that you can do slash things that's age
for instance and now you have two
dynamic parameters and the the names the
parameters have to match the names of
the function parameters if not you'll
get a very nice compile time error that
tells you hey these don't match you know
look here look here not the same please
figure it out what's going on and any
type that implements any type that
implements this trait called from Purim
is allowed so string implements from
pram that rocket influence from
parameter for uu8 also points from per
am and so you can use these things and
the semantics of this are that rocket
will call from per M for every parameter
you list and if the conversion succeeds
I affirm program says yep this is a
valid parameter of this type then it'll
call your handler otherwise it can't
call your handler and so it does it so
the implication of this is this thing is
rather simple but the implication of
this is actually deeper for instance if
we want to get a path from a user ie
we're gonna have a static file server so
we want a full path you know one very
common attack when people try to write
static file servers is to allow any file
to be read as opposed to just the files
in one particular directory and there
was like there's been like a bunch of
people on reddit slash trusts are like
look I wrote a static file server and
hyper and you know the first comment is
like oh I can read your password it's
great and so and so even here even
something as simple was for parameters
we can rocket protects you here so for
instance this is how you write a file
server in rocket and it's totally safe
and so what happens here what's
happening here is well we've added these
dot dots I'm not gonna explain them but
all it says is that you're matching
not only this segment but every segment
thereafter then we're capturing that in
a path parameter which is a path buff
and the front prime notation for path
buff will actually verify the path and
ensure that you are not la you cannot
have a directory traversal attack and so
this is exactly what this is in fact
what we put in the guide about how you
write a static file server in rocket and
it's safe and you're protected alright
so the last thing you want to talk about
before we talk about how this actually
working is what I believe the most
exciting part about rocket and that's
this concept of request guards so for
what we've seen so far rocket helps you
with input validation but there's
there's more to it than just the path
there's arbitrary data in the request
and you want to make sure that this
request contains some information for
instance I want to check that it
identifies an admin user well there's
nothing to match in the path for that
there's really nothing it's just
arbitrary how what an admin user is
maybe it means looking at the cookie
maybe it means looking at a header who
knows so Rockets mechanism to be able to
to describe these kinds of validations
is our request guards so any route you
can list any number of parameters in the
handler that implement the trait from
request so here we have one and it's
admin user so we have some type admin
user and what the admin user type does
it implements this from request straight
and the trait will verify that the
request actually contains an admin user
and it'll convert whatever needs to to
give you a type that says yep there's an
admin user here and if they can't do
that well it has one of two options it
can either say it can either fail which
says no do not call any handler that
needs an admin user or it can forward
which says okay look this route don't
call it I it's not an end user maybe
someone else can validate the request
maybe try a different kind of easier or
whatever just try something else rocket
and when you forward something rocket
will try the next route that the
nomenclature or whatever we say is to
collide so for example here we have two
routes and they are both requests there
but they're both match the admin route
the admin path for get requests so these
these collide and if you were to
actually run this rocket would say hey
these collide but we can fix that
collision by ranking these routes so we
can add this rank equals two to our
routes and that means hey when there's a
collision try the thing with the lowest
rank and then try to think with the next
highest rank and so on and so forth and
like I said if you do this wrong rocky
will give you an ideally a very helpful
error here it is that says rocket failed
to launch because there are collisions
these two things collide you know please
fix them oh by the way did you know
about ranking that's sometimes fix is
this okay so you have this so what's
gonna happen here well if you were to go
to get slash admin then rocket will try
the lowest ranked route first so that's
the one with the admin user which means
you need an admin user to be validated
to be authenticated by the request and
then if that fails rocket will try the
next ranked route which is the one below
that which says you just need a regular
user and so what we've done here is
actually implemented both authentication
and authorization so we've actually
encoded our policy with routes requests
cards and forwarding mechanism and we
can go further and keep ranking things
so for instance if you want to have a
router that has no requirements maybe to
tell the user hey login so I can figure
out if you're actually an admin user or
regular user then we can do that so I
think this is the most exciting part
about rocket is the ability to really
encode armed for the authentication
authorization or whatever request cards
and forwarding allow you to do that okay
so that's really all I want to say about
rocket there is a lot more and so I mean
you can do pretty much whatever you want
so there's a lot that I'm not going over
I will link you to rocket website which
has a guide it's pretty extensive the
documentation is very it's fairly
extensive it talks about much much more
that I just don't have time to cover ok
so next up is code generation in rocket
and rust so let's go back to our hello
world example here it is we have our
route or hi routes
or the root path and then we however
have our main function now reached out
it a bit because I need to fit code in
the slide so what does rocket what code
does rocket generate when you write this
program well it generates this code gray
yay what is this well let's watch let's
walk through it so the first thing that
happens is rocket takes your route
attribute and the signature of the
function and generates this route info
structure and really you can sort of
just map it directly you can see exactly
how the mapping works it takes the name
makes it a string takes the method makes
it an actual method type takes the path
puts it in a string this handler we'll
talk about in a second and for minute
rank or other aspects of rocket that we
don't have time to talk about the next
thing it does is it generates this this
function at the bottom here so that's
this high route that's what that handler
is and what this is it's a it's a modern
war physician of of every route so it is
taking any possible signature that you
can write and converting it into one
signature because at the end of the day
we are statically typed we can't take a
bunch of different signatures without
doing dynamic dispatch so we create one
signature that effectively does dynamic
dispatch at at compile time and all it
does is it will call that function so
what you actually wrote it'll get that
response and it will generate an outcome
from that response and the outcome is
just what happens when you actually try
to write that out
on the network and finally to tie things
back together we have that routes bang
macro in the mount in the mount and all
we do here is we construct a route from
the static information that we generated
so that routes bang becomes a Beck and
the vector contains all the routes and
that you that you wrote in the routes
and rocket will do all the name matching
necessary to actually make that happen
so that is the code that rocket
generates actually pretty
straightforward and the most interesting
or the key here is this monomorphic
function here it's that we can take any
signature and convert it into a function
that has a static type that has one type
okay so this is a pretty simple example
but what about when we have guards and
parameters what code gets generated here
well the code for the route info is
pretty much the same we just kind of
read everything parse everything and
birth that into a route info structure
and then rocket has all its information
to be able to convert it into something
that we can use at runtime for routing
but the code for the for the guard and
the parameters is is more involved and I
could not fit the code that rocket
generates so I you know took the code
that rocket generates and like rewrote
it into what you might actually write by
hand but even that won't check so I've
actually had to fuzz the types to fit
this into one slide but note that it is
it is pure to what actually was actually
rocket is actually generating so what
code is rocket generate we're gonna move
this function up here so we have room
for the code and this is what rocky
generates again it's a it's a function
that goes from request to outcome just
as before it's always gonna be that and
what it does inside is sort of what
you'd expect so for every parameter it
generates a little bit of code so for
instance for this user parameter it
generates the code that calls from
request for a user and it checks the
outcome of that of that call and it does
what you might expect if if it's
successful it gives you that value if
it's a forward it just forwards the
entire request and if it's a failure it
it fails with that status code well what
does it do for ID something very very
similar it calls the from per am
implementing and if that succeeds then
you get a value and if that does not
succeed then you forward the request to
says hey try something else and this
really is the code that rocket will
generate modulo making it very pretty to
fit in this slide alright so in summary
this is all the code generation that
rocket does it takes that route
attribute and generates a route info
structure a static route information
structure it takes your route handler
and it mount amorphous is it into
something that goes from request to
outcome and then it takes your routes
bang and converts it into a vector that
containing routes that match your static
route information
that's that's it if you tell me this is
magic then I don't know what magic is
this is super simple if you if you just
sat and thought about it this is
probably what you do this is this is not
something super complicated
you can cargo expand you know before you
compile you can do rocket coach and
debug equals one that will show you
exactly the code that rocket is emitting
and there's no magic it's just doing
things that you would do otherwise in
your handler for you so you don't have
to so you don't get it wrong so you do
the right thing every single time okay
how does this work how does rocket make
this cogeneration happen so let's talk a
bit about the internals so the
procedural macro API is actually pretty
simple rust will call you and it will
give you the syntax that say the
attribute was applied to or the syntax
inside of a macro of a macro call and
then your job is to take that syntax and
emit other syntax that it should replace
whatever Xin whatever syntax was called
with with so you take some syntax return
some syntax that's it pretty really
rather simple the types of this syntax
thing and I've simplified it but this is
effectively what's going on syntax it's
really just a vector of these token tree
things and a token tree contains a node
so like for instance a semicolon or a
plus or a string literal or something
like that and a span which says here is
where in the code this token occurred
and the span is useful for error
reporting and things of that nature the
span is not something that you can
actually get with derive for instance so
if you were to derive the span
information it's just gone you panic and
you can't tell the user why you're
panicking just you know try to explain
what's going on
but spans are extremely important and
they will be in the proc macros 2.0 API
so this is sort of what it looks like
now and what it will look like in the
future except much much much much
simpler so this is the feature the
present is money the future is much
nicer all right so that is code
generation in rocket and rust
so what's next what's coming up well
we're gonna keep using cogeneration is
you might imagine and we're gonna do
type your eyes the next thing the next
for the next release of rocket I really
want to have typed you our eyes and the
idea is if you have a route like this
that takes in a a parameter of ID that
you can then create a URL to that route
using the actual type that you expect so
for instance I can call URL bang for the
retrieved route and specify that the ID
is a paste idea of 100 or will actually
call you know into for you automatically
so you can just give anything that
implements into for your type in this
case seeing you size or whatever you 32
implemented into for paste ID then we
could just write the thing at the bottom
and the nice thing of course is that if
you get this wrong you'll get an error
that says nope those are not the right
types so you might imagine changing URLs
and then everywhere you try to generate
a URL for that new route it'll fail at
compile time
which is a really nice profit to have in
this case we'll just get you know slash
100 so it's just replacing that ID with
you know whatever you pass in and
getting slash 100 pretty straight board
the next thing we're gonna do is
database support so to use databases
with rocket now it's it's a bit
cumbersome this is what you write your
to do it this is what you would have to
write you can do it but it's not super
elegant it's gonna get much much simpler
so what I want this to look like in
version 0.4 is like this so in your
rocket gamma file you can specify I have
database name to my DB and the adapter
is Diesel's SQLite and then in your your
actual rocket file in your code you
would just derive some traits and tell
rocket oh the database that I want to
access what this type is my DB and then
you can just use that type as a request
guard in your code and so it really is
you know taking something very big -
something very small to make things
really nice and easy to use again we
really want to get rid of this
boilerplate but we still want to keep
type taking
so that's all I have to say what's
coming next at this point you've heard
all about rocket you've have some idea
about how cogeneration works in rocket
and I could end the talk here but I
thought I'd have some fun at the end of
this and and trying to dispel some myths
about rocket it's very interesting what
happens when you release something and
then you let other people tell you about
the thing you just released I feel like
the web is like anything that has to do
with the web is particularly sensitive
to this topic people have very strong
opinions about the web and then we get
JavaScript so I don't know how this
works so the most or yeah this is an
opinion it's not really a myth but I
think it's a myth and that's that
there's way too much magic in rocket you
know I don't know what's going on
hopefully now you're convinced that
that's just not true
what rocket is doing with cogeneration
is simple it's what you would write
except it's writing it for you so why
why do something the computer can do for
you when you gonna do the same thing
over and over and over again hopefully
those of you who thought there was too
much magic you're not convinced that
there is in fact not too much magic
there's just cogeneration the next sort
of myth is that rocket is somehow
unstable and if you've used rocket you
might think well of course rocket is
unstable it's using nightly and if you
look at the list of features that rocket
uses there's a lot of rocket uses a lot
of nightly features want me to tell you
that that's true but rocket is not
unstable rocket is stable in December
sense if you use rocket 0.3 Rocky 0.3
0.1 will not break your application not
sure where this why people started
saying this but just because rocket uses
lightly doesn't mean that you're a
rocket application itself is unstable it
means that we have to keep track of
nightly we have to keep track of nightly
and we do keep track of mentally there
at most in the history of rock there has
been there have been 24 hours between a
new nightly breaking something in rocket
and a new release of rocket fixing
itself for that nightly so at worst if
you'd like update your rot year rust
insulation every single day you wait 24
hours and there's a brand new release of
rocket
works on on the latest nightly or you
can just stick on the latest nightly and
it'll just keep working so rocket a
rocket applications are not unstable and
finally on the topic of nightly is that
rocket is forever on nightly I should
not try using rocket because my company
yeah we use stable software every day
that's all we use in our company stable
software we don't use npm 5.0 we use you
know MP m 4.0 because that's that's
stable I think no I know but well we can
talk about that one later alright so you
know if I want to use rocket that I'm
committing to to nightly and you know
nightly does make things like deploying
more difficult and things of that nature
so is rocket for ever on nightly well
rocket ever work on stable well yes of
course rocket will eventually work on
stable every single feature that rocket
uses is being worked on right now for
stabilization every single one of them
some of them are actually not needed
it's just because we're using unstable
stuff we actually need to use more
unstable stuff but everything that
rocket is using is being worked on right
now the procedure of macros are being
worked on right now you know everything
the rocket uses a specialization
everything the rocket uses it's being
worked on right now when is it gonna
happen I don't know that depends on
these guys over here
some things are hard like specialization
is hard it's it's not an easy problem so
it will happen maybe you know this 2019
Russ thing maybe that'll get it I'm
hopeful it'll happen much much much much
sooner than that like within a year it
seems like there's enough progress to
get there but we'll see we'll see where
that goes
but it is not forever and nightly it
will work on stable and I am committed
to having it work on stable as soon as
soon as possible including writing you
know code and rust to make rocket happen
I had to write a bunch of code in the
Russ compiler and I'm committed to do
that again to make it work on stable as
soon as possible so that's rocket that's
all I have to say about rocketing
cogeneration take a look at cogeneration
if you're trying to do something the
computer can do for you in a really nice
way you know particularly in
cogeneration the api's would get much
better
they're already better in nightly and I
think cogeneration can really improve
the simplicity of api's and their
robustness and applications using
libraries that use cogeneration here's
the website there is a guide there's a
really long guide there are tutorials
there's a bunch of Russ stocks there's
news and you can there's a link to the
github repository I'm Sergio here's my
email and thank you for your time
[Applause]